[Music]
i'm emily allred curator at the world
chess hall of fame
in august 2021 people around missouri
commemorated the state's bicentennial as
part of these celebrations a life-size
granite chessboard will be installed at
a new park on adrian's island in
jefferson city missouri
surrounding the board will be 32 images
representing the contributions that
missourians have made in varied fields
including agriculture
music
literature
and sports
the board will also educate visitors
about significant historical moments and
personalities from the state's history
including president harry s truman dredd
and harriet scott's courageous efforts
to gain their freedom innovations of
george washington carver
the project was spearheaded by dr
jeannie karen sinkfield the co-founder
of the st louis chess campus
the chessboard is the eagle scout
project for andrew dowden a live scout
and student at helios catholic high
school in jefferson city missouri
he completed the engravings on the
stones surrounding the chessboard using
an epilogue laser at the scouts bsa
invention campus
around the board will be benches made
from 200 year old wood by life scout
maya thomas a student at kirksville high
school in kirksville missouri as a part
of her eagle scout project
on august 9th the efforts of both scouts
were honored during a ceremony
commemorating the dedication of the
bicentennial bridge which was attended
by governor mike parson lieutenant
governor mike kehoe and the mayor of
jefferson city carrie turjan
a free brochure is available on-site at
the world chess hall of fame
and for download at world chess
worldchesthof.org
it contains passages about the
historical moments memorialized on each
of the squares as well as information
about the efforts of the scouts who made
this project a reality
you